if someone bugs you you should note that
and you shouldn't do anything about it
probably if they bug you twice the same
way then you think oh okay that's twice
but probably still you shouldn't do
anything about it but if they bug you
three times then you can say here's what
you just did and they'll say well no I
didn't do that yeah you did and you did
exactly the same thing in this other
situation so don't be telling me you
didn't do it cuz you did it three times
and I watched okay now they come up with
reasons they did it and maybe some of
them have to do with what a stupid son
of a you are and you should listen
because
maybe they're right but that's at least
the beginnings of the process by which
you unravel the problems you want to
figure out well we don't want to do this
this isn't the way we want to treat each
other we want to get to a place where
our whole life is like the best moments
of the best dates we ever had that's a
good goal that's attainable you got to
work man